[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
conflit - classique la maca si
j'ai fait beaucoup plus cambrai comme
non comme le beau spectacle de son
et réserver tous cambrai mois
[Musique]
très souriante un sourire hollywood
détour beaucoup
[Musique]
parfait merci alors là un bon soir on
vient de voir qu'il n'a steurs piste qui
est la 200e girls du crazy oui alors
comment tu l'a choisi d'abord comment tu
l'a rencontré mais c'est la première
fois justement que je ne choisis pas une
danseuse c'est elle qui nous a choisi sa
salle a fait son casting de tous les
choses qui en europe elle est venue
l'été dernier au crazy alors qu'elle
travaillait à monte carlo dans le palais
de l'ops et puis elle a dit c'est cet
endroit où je veux travailler et écrire
il l'a tellement envoyer sa photo ses
lunettes alors je lui ai envoyé un
ticket d'avion qu'elle vienne pour moi
ni vraiment les bornes en secret elle a
fait une audition qui a été tout ce qui
a pu conclure et alors comment tu l'a
choisie à cause de quoi dujon bien elle
est en somme elle résume tout ce qu'ont
été les danseuses du crazy depuis 35 ans
avant donc la 200e s'est pas lassé pas
là tu es un nom mais elle est belle un
danseur les très professionnelle jusqu'à
l'état en train d'apprendre selon la
revue et mon dieu elle bouge bien et je
crois qu'il est très motivé tu fais
combien d'audition par an à peu près
oulala pour combien deux ou trois mille
ah bon tu vois que deux ou trois mille
fit défiler par an chez nous parce qu'on
fait des auditions tous les tous les
mois le marny premier mardi du mois et
on a 30 40 danseuse qui viennent dans ce
moment sur les quels sont les critères
de sélection mais il faut qu'elles aient
un long cou tandis qu'à deux c'est ce
cas là non couché qui - sr d'ailleurs
c'est la même chose pour les modèles et
qu'elle ait un minimum d'années soit 810
et les genoux non nous très très
bon ça se fait que tu sais que ça sera
un peu parce que je me suis renseigné
sur toi les jeux c'est très rare et très
joli et c'est vrai que le sein droit est
toujours moins beau que sa gauche oui le
salindrois masse assez c'est patrick
disent tous les médecins qui s'occupent
d'elle le ca dessous les sinologues oui
ils ont remarqué que c'est un noir est
moins beau alors une fois qu'elle est
rentrée au crédit comment ça se passe
elle gagne combien par mois par exemple
au début elle a un salaire d'attentes
pour les deux premiers mois de
15 mille fois par mois pour décider ce
qu'elle fera si l'on a seulement les
ensembles où les solos du terrain alors
elle comme je pense qu'elle va être
soliste elle gagnera plus après oui ben
oui elle peut aller jusqu'à 20 c'est
vrai qu'à une discipline de fer par
exemple qu elles sont ramenées en
minicar que oui ça l'est dans les loges
exams mais le président d'un théâtre
s'est passé pas naître il ya des mecs et
ont proposé de racheter des racheter des
filles du crazy pas encore nos c'est
vraiment un défi dans la salle qui note
toutes les réactions des clients tournée
desquels je n en a quatre capitaines qui
sont d'ailleurs à l'intention des
anglaises de la troupe qui note tout ce
qu'il me faut un rapport le soir même et
une fois qu'elle sorte du quasi qu'est
ce qu'elle devienne ce film est bien 90%
se marient abord parce qu elles sont
arrivées au top dans leur position est 1
1 mu paul ii c'est donc elle tout le
métier elle se marie avec qui etc de
risa la chine ont bondi tout leur fair
et un journaliste à ministre et qu'en
même temps il reste au crazy environ 5-6
ans et rita renoir ça fait beaucoup plus
longtemps qu'elle va on rit tard elle
s'est présentée elle c'était en 1952 ah
oui oui elle restée deux ans et pour
être fait épouser leur humour c'est
envoie trois villes parce que c'est la
plus charmante la plume elle plus
intelligente que la plus douce si très
douce je gagne beaucoup d'argent ont
déjà investi tout c'est alain longuent
nouveau crazy cavan rire en décembre
prochain une salle de 400 places se
battre concurrence wright tech non il
n'y a pas de concurrence pour éviter les
âges c'est pas comme vous la télé mais
nous on a cinq autres chaînes bon ben
maintenant on va voir donc les deux
numéros qu'elle fait social entre van
wyk elle apprend qu'à la provocation
[Musique]
bonsoir
j'ai pas fini
[Musique]
nouvelle la mairie du christ je suis la
poubelle les filles
quand je rentre en scène je ne sais pas
trop pourquoi les hommes les vrais ne
regarde plus
moi
écoutez là mais pas s'aimer même sens
oui oui tu le donnes incendie attention
les filles moi j'ai un homme important
dans un cadeau des rivières de diamants
jeune homme important cette norme tard
compta c'est très bien c'est une rivière
puma
[Musique]
saddam
soit le
bon
m
ou alors marilyn d'habitude c'est toi
qui est derrière la porte et les gens
qui sont devant la porte c'est toi qui
les laisse rentrer ou pas rentré au banc
ce soir on est tous les deux sur
l'escalier c'est normal c'est le 31
décembre qu'est-ce que d'abord toi tu te
souhaite à toi pour l'année 88 il reste
au bas toute l'année durant des années
c'est bien là
la deuxième chose maintenant qu'est ce
que tu souhaites au monde entier pour
l'année 88 la ponce qui veut la paix
[Rires]
les deux
[Musique]
88 évidemment je me souhaite de bourg et
le rex ouais
et puis les spectateurs soient bons
soient heureux et maintenant ce que tu
souhaites au monde
monde entier monde entier les noirs les
jaunes des millionnaires aujourd'hui je
leur souhaite une bonne année mais voilà
tout ça c'est un barbu cancer
[Applaudissements]
écoute c'est sympathique ce petit réveil
ont d'abord je te souhaite pas encore
une bonne année mais pratiquement
voiture je me souhaite jamais rien parce
que j'ai j'ai eu jusqu'ici et je
touchais pas de boire dans le tech dont
j'ai très peur ils
rien du jardin ça c'est du bois s'est
dit agacé didier ché travail alors j'ai
toujours beaucoup de chance dans la vie
ouais et je préfère souhaité un tas de
choses aux gens qui ont manqué ouais
plutôt je trouve que c'est assez c'est
assez
c'est moche de se souhaiter quelque
chose quand on est la réussite qu'ils
souhaitent des émetteurs quand même
alors ça c'est derrière
moi je crois que pour moi il y a
la chose la plus importante ça paraît
super banal ans mais vas-y parce que
c'est bien la chose la plus importante
c'est la paix voilà très bien mais ça je
crois que c'est un voeu et la sq a peu
de chance de se réaliser avec tous les
singles et qui qui sévissent un peu
partout ça empêche pas de le souhaiter
je crois qu'on peut ne sait pas
toutefois si je dis ça si je réfléchis
pas mais quand on peut souhaiter aux
gens la paix quand on peut souhaiter à
aux mômes d'être heureux doit être fait
n'importe comment et pour vivre
n'importe quoi mais d'être fait par des
gens qui allaient font pas par hasard
mais qu en vue d'assurer leur bonheur et
à les aimer bon déjà toi on a fait deux
choses qui sont pas petit qui s'endort
bien sûr j'espère sont pas des vitraux
pieux mais non mais les besoins
du reste il a à faire démarrer l'année
tu vois clara sérieusement car
sérieusement c'est bien c'est très bien
on va stéphane à la tienne à la dérive
andrée putman que vous souhaitez vous à
vous pour la nouvelle année
la paresse la paresse vie et que
souhaitait travailler moins et au monde
que souhaitez-vous au monde la douce un
la douceur la poussée par la balle très
bien merci encore des choses douces
catch ça pour la vôtre
est bon ça va
[Musique]
me
je
[Musique]
la façon comme
fallait que j'y secours
non
[Musique]
la famille
résa
tout dire
[Musique]
les 106
ça
[Musique]
nous
oui
j'ai
mais où
je
[Musique]
ok
sous
je n'ai pas
[Musique]
ce n'est pas une fille c'est un garçon
ce n'est pas steve de mosnac c'est une
niche est
[Musique]
pas plus
bon alors il va être quels sont tes
projets pour 88 alors là j'ai des
projets un très beau projet mais tu me
permettra de garder le secret parole
[Applaudissements]
du
dal et non dire à personne les cours
n'ont cessé tôt non je ne peux pas le
dire je ne peux pas le dire c'est quoi
ce pas le dire je vais me déguiser un
charlot ah bon je viens et ça j'ai fait
un numéro de music hall je vais faire
une tournée ça allait charlot qui se
rendent à bordeaux où tu vois c'est bien
alors ça se prépare ça en train de se
préparer ce pari
et qu'est ce que tu souhaites au jour
pour l'année 80 alors moi ce que je
souhaite c'est vraiment une chose
[Musique]
très sincèrement je dirais beaucoup
d'amour
[Musique]
se tendre la main à tous les enfants du
monde soit heureux et ce sourire
que l'on s'amuse énormément avec
l'accordéon les autres extrêmement aussi
voilà donc wifi merci
beaucoup de beaux jours devant elles
souhaiter une bonne année aux français
l'ont projet le vendeur balader
1988 en zone euro veulent que je
voudrais qu'il soit placé l'espace ou le
chili mais pourquoi le sol et parce que
j'adore l'afrique quand je joue je
préfère le ferai mais le jeune afrique
est alors j'aimerais que ce soit des
zoulous solex et je dois vous couvrira
toute française à cette voie vous
couvrir de bisous
bonjour correspond aux deux bisous bonne
année
1988 bah
ya que lui qui voit les champagnes moi
j'ai la bouteille a tué ma biche fois la
mise voilà vous faire
je le tiens bien
je peux boire dans la gueule j'aime bien
c'est quand il est coupé mais non mais
justement c'est là où on va voir si tu
sais bien faire
voilà
tient le bien c'est comme dans le clip
ses coactionnaires et c'est quoi
des best of est très bon
bon alors qu'est-ce qu'on s'emmerde
merde bon alors c'est quoi que tu que
ton ambition ultime pour l'année 88 mon
ambition ultime pour l'année 88 un
spectacle à la fin de l'année ah bon oui
c'est pas de refaire un succès comme
etienne etienne en beauce imams alors
dit le vent pas le site une demande pas
au bon dieu je vais te donner as-tu
propose une m'en aller où la hausse ou
je fais une union heureuse je me méfie
des fois ci c'est pas plus en avant
alors c'est ça oui bon alors un autre
succès comme etienne etienne oui il va
être mieux d'ailleurs être mieux encore
les deux qu'est ce que tu souhaites aux
gens pour l'année quand même
ça va être compliqué la composante y ait
un peu moins de l'acheter pendant qu'on
y est ça se rappelle m et puis peu moins
d'hypocrisie et puis on remonte ses
manches on a des couilles au cul
[Rires]
[Musique]
merci
bonsoir
car c'est la caricature c'est
l'exaltation des sentiments qui rend
l'artiste provocante regardez john
waters et c'est monstrueux famille de
travestis regardez jean marie rivière et
sète frontignan de l'alcazar
et sans champagne brut
regarder enfin cette gouttelettes
ruisselante
qui me font au fond de la gorge et qui
va se ramasser après en des goules y
aller maintenant champagne et cotillons
pour tout le monde dans ce paradis de
décibels et de lumière bonsoir sans fil
salut
[Musique]
m
les plaquettes
non
et
[Musique]
acheter
semaine
[Musique]
aïe
m
[Musique]
et
ce serait
m
[Musique]
des
goodies miles
fonera
poite que l'esma
mae
m
[Musique]
à
m
je te plaît
merci souris
[Musique]
et
moi
m
l'apa
et b
m
[Musique]
c'est ça
m
[Musique]
non
oui
[Musique]
à la riviera
attendez
attaquer
[Musique]
bravo les messieurs t salut michou j'ai
coupé jamais copté michaud que je salue
ouvertement français changent il est
gentil de me saluer ouvertement je viens
moi monsieur le premier ministre a qu à
votre santé à vos prouesses pour 1988
plein trip c'est que ça va là je fais je
me place dans les régions pauvres
et puis nous voulions pas de si vous
avez un petit poste au ministère de l'
de la culture eva n'oubliez pas me jouer
c'est michel
ne vous inquiétez pas je pourvoir est en
chaque domaine comme j'ai toujours été
très fermé près délicat j'ai toujours
veillé à placer mes tops un compact
d'abord à tous les ministères je suis
très content nous vous avons ce soir et
je vous souhaite les choux pas nommé et
une heureuse à votre santé jacques
[Musique]
comme tout
et
merci à lalo schifrin tue beaucoup moins
connue que ta musique finalement et
cette musique géniale qui a fait le tour
du monde sur laquelle on danse encore
aujourd'hui à paris dans un endroit à
temps je citerai pas le nom tous les
mardis soirs fric tu joues trois
extraits de thé composition et puis
ensuite les gens comprendront qui tu es
2 oh
ça c'est mannix
lalo schifrin en avant il y en a un
autre qui est pas mal aussi ses missions
apc les enfants petits bouts
[Musique]
m
merci non c'est dingue parce que quand
cette dans cette boîte a ouvert il ya
dix ans c'est là dessus qu'on dansait
avec philippe roux tchéou à mai ont
dansé sur mission impossible rivas un
troisième que je voudrais que la
gentillesse de jouer parce que alors là
c'est le tube total en france c'est les
babines
à
merci
alors merci beaucoup je suis très
heureux parce que il fait vraiment
partie des gens que j'idolâtre un peu et
j'aurais jamais pensé que je te
rencontrerait je connais ces tendances
charité fait ça mais j'aurais jamais
pensé avoir la chance de te rencontrer
un jour je suis très très heureux que tu
sois là je suis très contente d'être ici
c'est très à l'aise c'est sarkozy c'est
vraiment tout va bien alors il ya une
chose que par contre que je ne savais
pas et ça m'a pas tellement étonné parce
qu'on adore les argentins à paris c'est
que tu argenté en fait oui nabinaud sais
pas si c'est ça j'ai fait mes études de
musique classique et aussi j'ai dû gérer
la musique et la musique de film mais
maintenant je reviens à paris les 26
déjà un vivier pour faire au cas des
champs elysées le virus pichard oui pour
les vieilles spéciale à tous les ans
handicapée indicateurs au vert une gala
avec l'orchestré harmonique de paris oui
et on va jouer pour première fois en
europe un concerto pour contrer pas sûr
qu est ce que tu as écrit j'ai écrit ce
que tu écris aussi la musique classique
oui mais ça tu as fait du jazz avec stan
getz avec sarah vonn avec les eagles
bits
mais je veux dire que la musique la city
ont va faire c'est très excitant on va
faire tout ce qu'elle savait ni ni vote
ravel ma mère voir avec est le
concepteur de contrat va si on l'appelle
classique mais hélas beaucoup de
vitalité vigueur j'espère que
ces 26 janvier au théâtre des
champs-elysées que c'est sûr tu peux
nous en jouer un petit bout oui et
concerto classique que tu vas jouer le
26 juin à ça je ne sais pas mais
je vais jouer en d2 thème le concerto de
contrebasse
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]
aurélie quels sont tes projets en 88
90 ouais c'est ça plane pour faire et de
plein de nouvelles chansons et puis
voilà les toits etienne teboh
journalistes sur le fou je sais pas si
c'est encore 88 points j'espère
une tournure tout ce qu'ils ont
c'est honteux les mêmes projections de
toute façon ce ne sont pas un aiguillon
et alors qu'est ce que tu souhaites les
gens 88
nous souhaitons monde entier à regarder
couet
lannes d'amour qu'il avait beaucoup de
villes très
dès le coup de rupture socialisme
vu les affiches
[Musique]
partout
le chat botté
quand on chante qu'est ce que tu
souhaites pour la nouvelle année ce que
je souhaite c'est enregistré mon 45
tours et revendeur ouais tu vas chanter
une chanson de brassens sur une face et
puis sur l'autre face une chanson de may
cry giacchino en ce moment c'est ce
tracé sa soeur qui raccorde va j'espère
ça m'a sorti en verre
avril n'est pas le premier âge
et toi qu'est ce que tu souhaites pour
la bonne année je souhaite
gagner je
change de métier de l'année
c'est à dire que jean parent méfier mais
on s'attaque à de nouveau mis cet
avantage social
woerth
qu'est ce tu souhaites avons
choisi et d'après dans le monde pour
qu'on puisse s'éclater qui sont
conscients je vous dis bien rigolé à
samedi
il arrive d'avoir des comptes sur la
gueule et que ce soit aussi un endroit
qu'on fasse la bande mais ma mère outre
oui ça exactement ma nature
[Musique]
alors
tous les choux de la nouvelle année
ouais et ont deux jeux se traîne voire
est inquiet dit il n'est pas nul dans le
dis à tous les signes du monde entier
c'est différent les voix des musulmans
qui ont début 2012 il n'est pas lille
donc simplement savoir apple innocence à
votre fraîcheur là tout n'est pas noir
toi jean qu'est ce que tu souhaites pour
la nouvelle année
je souhaite une année là
monde non vous passer autant de choses
que dans un siècle
saboun même que on passe des années on a
pré sente pas grave et qu'il pourrait
que la prochaine on ait l'impression de
vraiment l'avoir vécu et que
de tous les côtés en
émotions 1
des veines moment
et quelque chose est évidemment positive
[Musique]
la ruse
par essence et l'état c'est vraiment la
fares ou trop de quoi
apparemment
[Musique]
et heureuse et la plus heureuse des
paresseux
les matières c'est la ouate qu'elle
préfère la civelle les français
j'ai deux soit il ouah toutes les
matières c'est la ouate qu'elle préfère
passive elle est possible
j'ai deux soirs
[Musique]
les
ok avec 1,2 dans
la zone
m
[Musique]
il inquiet ellaone café
même s'ils veulent
la ouate qu'elle préfère pas si nouvelle
oui
j'ai lu toi et lauaki toutes les
matières et la loi de calais
[Musique]
en direct de chez michou c'était
caroline loeb
à michel mercier bon libre à roger
peyrefitte bonsoir mes choux pour faire
tapisserie savez monsieur jean michel
mercier ou publier un livre chez carla
font que sa belle angelica corps perdu
et finalement quand on lit les
interviews vous avez donné depuis
quelques années et est toujours
extrêmement discrète afin que le
journaliste essayer de vous allez un
petit peu plus loin nous poser des
questions un peu indiscrètes vous
fermiez comme ça etc alors d'un seul
coup vous nous faites un livre de 500
pages comment ça se fait vous êtes bien
d'argent
ça aussi comme tout le monde oui
mais ce n'est pas mon propos quel est
votre propos à la non là je pense que
effectivement je voulais mettre
peut-être comme on dit les pendules à
l'heure
on a eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui n'étaient pas justes et
justifiées
j'ai vécu effectivement nba
évidente de cette personne le sage je
n'ai jamais profité d'une publicité dont
j'aurais pu profiter dans certains cas
et puis un jour j'ai eu une fois de plus
un grand chagrin d'amour
et je ne savais plus quoi faire j'ai
quitté le pays où j'étais c'était
l'italie à l'époque n'est ce pas roger
je crois que roger très éprouvant et je
suis revenu en france un peu désespérée
en menant ce que j'allais faire
j'ai beaucoup travaillé toute ma vie
et lorsque je me suis retrouvé à paris
comme ça perdu
j'ai eu le besoin ressenti le besoin
d'écrire ma vie comme si un peu jaloux
disparaître pas vraiment attention le
prenez pas mal mais comme si j'allais
partir et avant de partir où que ce soit
sur une île déserte peut être
durablement il ya longtemps j'y pense
laisser quand même
le sentiment de ce que j'avais vécu
comprendre dit ce que j'avais fait rêver
vous dites les hommes ont brisé c'est
comme angélique les hommes ont brisé
alors qu'est-ce que vous ont fait les
hommes je leur ai tout donné je leur est
donné j'ai souvent arrêter ma carrière
pour les suivre parce que vous aimez
et leurs enfants parce que
des hommes qu'avec une famille
[Musique]
va vous
où
divorcé depuis longtemps
et j'ai aimé ces femmes ces enfants
et chaque fois j'ai dû tout est bon
avant une autre
qu'ils m'ont quitté pour l'un et l'autre
j'ai quitté non seulement un orgueil
familles et des enfants que j'étais les
hommes ont brisé la carrière de marie
paule un peu brisé vous même en
acceptant des films qui étaient pas
toujours formidable bon alors là je veux
dire je crois que tout le monde accepte
des films sont pas formidables au débat
au départ comme vous lisez un manuscrit
d'un livre vous pensez qu'ils formidable
alors vous le faites ensuite scellé
tournée d'une manière qui n'est
peut-être pas adapté
olive vous avez fait les supernovae
c'est le plus gros super nanny que vous
avez fait c'est quoi on vous n'aurez
jamais vu
et
merci c'est normal j'ai appris mon
métier en faisant des nappes est comme
ça je pouvais à prélever
voir exactement sans fin ne pas faire on
ne sait jamais au départ
je vous fais la préface du livre de
michel mercier parce que
chaque jour je crois à deux choses
sur lesquels repose ma vie en dehors de
l'amour de la langue française j'ai
l'amour tout court et la musique et la
vieille amitié que jaime morales
shell et qui est confirmée encore par le
plaisir que je viens d'avoir à l'entente
[Musique]
a été
et
la fait enfin l'objet la même
satisfaction quand j'ai joly parce que
je savais que c'est une femme qui en
dehors de ces succès qui l'ont rendus
célèbre
croyaient à la mort croyait à l'amitié
les dons octroyés aux deux choses
auxquelles moi même je ne crois pas
roger peyrefitte une vision de michel
avait une vie aventureuse mais vous
aussi vous avez une vie très aventureuse
quand même vous avez des problèmes avec
la carrière diplomatique
monsieur bideau vous en voulez beaucoup
vous avez été réintégrés vous n'allez
jamais pu remettre diplômes annonce a
été jetée réintégrer puis ça a été
allégé ses intérêts par le conseil
d'état et ça a été annulé par le quai
d'orsay et alors cette fête c'est vous
dire que autrefois la dernière
jurisprudence et un conseiller d'état
est bien dedans on faire plus qu'on veut
et j'ai pas vous en dire comme je ne
cherchais pas à être réintégré
effectivement parce que la vraie
carrière c'est la littérature c'est à
dire la liberté ouais je n'ai pas poussé
au delà des
nécessaire la prétention grade
d'ambassadeur qu'est-ce que rick manger
droit est ce que vous avez eu envie de
rentrer à l'académie française
j'ai eu envie d'en dans laquelle
grossesse quand j'ai commencé d'écrire
je pense à laquelle bill française quand
j'étais déjà membre de l'académie plan
collège ça va grandir et ensuite
à une date bien défini j'ai choisi la
liberté comme disait l'autre et cette
date et 1964 quand j'écris ma lettre
ouverte en france à aurillac prendre
laquelle dix français le prix nobel de
littérature
c'est à dire que j'ai rompu avec tout ce
milieu-là hadjar est à jamais h à rennes
suit la can be délit je serais très
heureuse - je leur ai d'en faire partie
mais jamais je ne me présenterais or
jamais il risque et ne se présente pas
par conséquence à gâteau mais elle était
libérable disait assez plaisamment c'est
pas très gentil pour beaucoup âgées au
pénible je crois que t'as qu'a dit il
s'est trompé de pierre
[Rires]
je la retrouvais
je me suis trouvé un jour à gros riffs
gauche lui avait une vente d'objets
érotique de vote aux élections oui assez
sérieux j'espère que vous êtes avait
acquis quelques ça le sens tellement
cher
[Rires]
le lendemain d'un titre dans libération
d'un article dédié au caire game rivière
et qui disait maintenant on verrai plus
jamais ça dans libération c'est le titre
c'était super je le dis devant ces vieux
godemiché sur
iphone et que je serai le
terrain non oui parce qu'il y avait deux
magnifiques qui était de près columbia
c'est lesquels les meilleurs mais elle
avait duré des commissions
bond girl autre cadeau pour dallas avant
le 31 décembre
l'admission
les prix colonna je comprends qu'ils
fassent la lgv est allé parler
vraiment pas
mon dieu
[Rires]
voilà pour ton barbier de la voix
toujours très gai les histoires d'amour
on savait que ça revient et oui parce
que c'est vital la peur du sida oui
c'est que comme les coudes sont obligés
d'être fidèle oui ça ça revient c'est à
dire que c'est à dire que les gens sont
obligés de s'acheter des des gadgets et
tout ça on le sait rien il ya un boom
est un baume sur l'objet érotique sur le
code si vous vendiez maintenant vous
gagneriez encore plus d'argent belle
époque où ça vous allez gagner moins
vous savez ce qu'il a fait des choses
artistiques et
fragile
qu'est ce qui serait son été l'auteur
d'une série kung fu bd capot de la
vanille rose
n'a gagné 2 j'ai gagné deux ou trois
millions n'est pas quoi
vous avez besoin de tout cet argent
vient cet argent allait justement je
parler d'amour c'était là pour moi
c'était pour amoureux s'étaient labour
aussi sauter c'était pas une fondation
laure-gaudreault n'ont aucune fondation
personnelle c'était une fondation
représenté par une lettre qui avait fait
une très mauvaise affaire il fallait
courir tout ça par des ventes est riche
est-ce que vous êtes arrivé est ce que
vous êtes arrivé à renflouer quand même
je suis la langue
c'est réglé on verra
alors le chou est ce que tu mets moi je
suis très heureux d'être ici déjà huawei
et j'aurais déjà trinquer à cette fin
d'année est difficile très gazelle
entouré d'amis comme toi tu irais michel
aulas michel est mon ami roger obligé
tellement de ton breizh coeur à la santé
à la de l'année
je vois une autre copine yvette horner
qui lie à borisov
c'est pénible alors un années 80 et les
rues quand j'en vois pas franck autour
de groix où l'accouchement la
loi on
est ce que tu te souhaite pour la
briqueterie à tous les enfants autre
comédie
parce que je suis là
j'ai décidé de m'occuper d'ailleurs de
la direction le monde toujours rien
alors rumeur que c'est une chouette pour
la vie sauvage et ben je souhaite que la
synchro nouvelle mon contrat à l'achat
économie peu notre audition de
l'ancienne
et méfiance donc avec marie
[Applaudissements]
depuis un seul supporter statut
d'acteur
salah
c'est ma nounou
est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
génial ouais alors etienne roda-gil tea
party etienne tes voeux pour toi pour
l'année 88 pour tout le monde avant pour
toi pour moi que ça il le mieux possible
et pour tout le monde que le sud
remontent jusqu'au pôle rats ça c'est
une belle idée voilà philippe pour toi
d'abord là pour moi bah écoutez moi
j'aimerais bien d'abord que ma fille
continue à bien parler ouais si elle ne
parvient elle commence avec un petit
accent samedi ouais la naksa comme un
[__]
c'est comme en fait tout le monde qu'on
continue dans le monde entier à faire la
fête qu'on va se marrer classement que
88 comme la fan 96 bon revenons philippe
dernier point important le chapeau parce
que je vois qu'est-ce que signé
l'harmonie donne la leçon et à le
supprimer un bon selon qui une fois les
enfants allaient le faire on a
les bras
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après les baltes ichi club c'est un
white ce
qui cause territoire
chopin
[Musique]
m
non
tous
à
[Musique]
il avait des années qui
a tué ses scoops et avoir cette
exceptionnelle c'est une sur une
opération des masaï des asturies si
cette bonne année qu'est-ce que tu sois
au monde entier la paix la paix
[Musique]
je connais
doucet
[Musique]
non
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu te souhaite à toi pour
88 je me souhaite que 88 soit aussi bien
que les quatorze années que j'ai bien
passé en bateaux souhaitant repartir son
corps est absolument fou et qu'elles
soient tous souhaitent au monde entier
mais je souhaite au monde entier que
leur atteint 88 aussi bien que blanc a
déclaré s'appeler gaulliste
[Musique]
g
m
tous
[Musique]
oui
bon
[Musique]
b
mais où
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est
bien c'est le partenariat non qu'est-ce
qui le souhaitent à toi pour la d81 huit
mois l'année 88 sahara c'est même sa
belle et qu'elle tu souhaites au monde
entier alors à vache est que ce soit
aussi glaçant
du seigneur aussi parce que j'ai
plus de chances aux jeunes qui ont faim
c'est pour ça il est originaire a
longtemps pour ses 20 ans c'est vrai
c'est d'abord
qu'est-ce que tu te souhaite à toi pour
l'année 90 par la crise ont assuré m toi
tu que je vais plein de pognon noël
temps fou des trois manches elle veut
des jours c'est bon
je connais je me suis dit soit sa taille
face au tc viendra mais je compte m tu
veux que tout le monde aimerait me voir
là dedans on t'aime je te défiles te
désire mieux sauter nous souhaitons
vraiment inutile
bon
les mecs yayi est bienvenue mais
laissez-moi m'exprimer bordaises bon
salue les mecs je vous souhaite à toutes
une superbe année à tous aussi le
superbe année en espérant que moi je
reviendrai cette année au sommet au
sommet de mes possibilités matthew
conneries est ce que je veux dire c'est
que vos jantes en revenir au sommet et à
faire un super truc à wimbledon cette
année spécialement parce que j'adore
laird et puis bon je préfère le hc sûr
mais c'est vrai qu'on peut pas tout
avoir dans la vie et ce que je veux dire
c'est que le bon j'espère une superbe
année à tout le monde et surtout à moi
salut les merci beaucoup
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à moi rien de plus 87 si vous pouvez me
refaire de contrebasse la même s'est
vendu et qu'est ce que tu souhaites au
monde pour l'année 90 je crois je vais
pas être très original la paix le retour
des otages oui mais c'est bien
et toi alors que lou qu'est-ce que tu te
souhaite à toi à moi ou avec eux d'avoir
autant d'ennemis quand 80 cm parce qu'au
fond à 7 1% - dans ta danois sans moins
aisés mais c'est un bon si enfin qu'il
me reste quelques zones avec temps
restera fait quelques erreurs pour les
autres en quatre ans mais oui bien sûr
je souhaite la paix la paix dans le
monde c'est banal que les autres plein
d'argent qui va bientôt rawiri que les
gens mangent bien que je sois heureux
c'est beaucoup d'art
autrement dit on ici tout va poser un
problème ouais qui souhaitait mais
souhaitait parce que je cours à terre
d'autres
le souhaitais que filmant ses souhaits
et à centrer les travailleurs jean
ternois mais en vérité en un an sans
ordonnance
tu m'as rendu service
c'est en réfléchissant ce que j'allais
vous
j'ai découvert quelque chose et
comptines phrase
de la bible que je disais souvent je
comprenais pas
c'était la ville
j'ai mes deux ans de voir la vie et la
mort
la bénédiction la malédiction son pic ou
qui choisira et puis tout le monde ait
un consensus aujourd'hui tout le monde
est d'accord pour choisir la vie
on pense à la santé et à la santé de
notre on pense aussi aux petits-enfants
en ethiopie que margot fabiano crois
c'est ce que tu souhaites au monde c'est
la deuxième question ce que tu souhaites
au monde sait ça c'est cela attention ce
n'est pas fini
parce que je pense que je me suis je
réfléchissais je me suis dis je choisir
la vie c'est souhaiter la vie au monde
d'accord les tortionnaires sont aussi
des êtres vivants ce qui
c'est les gardiens des douleurs sont
aussi des êtres vivants qui j'ai compris
la seconde partie de la phrase la
bénédiction à la malédiction cela veut
dire que la vie oui mais avec la
bénédiction qu'à la dir est mal
addiction c'est mon père
violent je compte plus de traces que
très intense je souhaite alors on mange
du jour au moins aussi oui je me trompe
et c'est bien que nos compatriotes
la vie avec la police
à
[Musique]
boehler philippe alfonsi qu'est-ce que
tu te sois tu as toi pour la négation et
non comme je suis complètement shooté à
la télé
je
sais faire des gestes r mai
ce sont plein d'émissions auxquelles je
suis un peu sevré depuis un an jean
s'est décantée guerre dont la démission
c'est toi
montréal l'émission
perd un peu de provocation s'attendre à
des attaques si par l'action cast
faisant quelques années aujourd'hui
disposer une prédisposition m'amuserait
plus sombres prophéties sur l'a21
bourbourg
certaines limites et ça va mais cette
action sont bons c'est ce que tu te sois
ça serait rigolo non mais j'aimerais
bien monde sur la santé on nous a fait
des émissions dans n'importe quelle
scène cette mode complètement le moment
les gens une télé un zappeur trois ans
les gens qui avaient parlé et regardé
l'émission regardent des émissions
mais si chaîne arrive à voir plein de
bonnes émissions ça fait une série de
bonnes choses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
suite
[Musique]
oui
à
[Musique]
non
et
à
oui
[Musique]
à
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on n'a qu'à
c'est
il va
non
[Musique]
c'est pas une fille c'est un garçon
c'est pas mal de nas c'est une niche est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ban
barry le très heureux de te voir à paris
après si longtemps
j'ai vraiment le comeback de l'année ça
fait du bien d'entendre
enregistré plus de 100 disques et puis
tout d'un coup tu as disparu qu'est ce
qui s'est passé
j'ai eu des petits problèmes avec ma
maison de disques
j'ai essayé d'arranger ça
trouver des contrats mais ça n'a pas
marché
ça durait cinq ans
après je me suis un peu retirée par an
deux ans et demi pour ménager ma vie
privée pour essayer de trouver des fonds
communs maisons viennent d'ailleurs
quand j'ai vu que j'arrivais pas
j'ai décidé de reprendre ma carrière
c'est pour ça que je suis là
exit chose là dessus c'est vrai que tu
contribues beaucoup aux oeuvres de
charité pour les ghettos ouais
depuis toujours
je viens moi-même du ghetto je viens des
quartiers pauvres de los angeles
j'étais un petit voyou et j'ai eu des
ennuis quand j'étais adolescent les
bande d'aigris rentrer jacques
alors je comprend les problèmes des gens
pauvres ceux qui sont vraiment les
favorisent écoulée pour vous j'essaie de
les aider chaque fois que je prends
[Musique]
salut combien de temps pour devenir star
c'est un a pris 11 ans et demi c'est
vraiment très très longue
[Musique]
tu
as remarqué un truc c'est que dans le
monde les gens avaient des couleurs
différentes il avait les cuisines
différents mais il avait des trucs
différents mais avec un truc qu'ils
aient tous c'était faire l'amour chanté
l'amour ça ça marche partout
c'est ça ton secret bah c'est le plus
grand dénominateur commun
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les mains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et des gens qui disent baril on a
tellement écouté tes disques en faisant
l'amour qu'on a l'impression que des
fois tu mets en garde
c'est pas gênant de rentrer comme ça
dans la vie privée des gens
ça c'est le plus beau compliment qu'on
puisse faire la musique de paris
j'ai vraiment beaucoup de chance les
gens accorde une telle importance à la
musique qu'ils veulent qu'elle participe
à la relation les plus est pour des plus
intimes et je leur en suis très
reconnaissant et fait l'amour sur un
disque byword
moi ta recette nancy avait un cocktail
appelé le cocktail barry white ce serait
quoi la recette
la recette c'est
c'est la passion la justice le travail
la loyauté
parce qu'on fait être honnête dans ce
qu'on fait
vous trouvez un thème dont on a envie de
parler
barry white c'est l'amour d'autres c'est
la guerre
je suis une force positive
[Musique]
est temps que le monde continuera à se
perpétuer entre dans huit ans que les
gens continueront à faire l'amour temps
qui se multiplieront barry white sera là
avec eux
c'est ça la recette
cette dernière chanson s'appelle the
right man
c'est quoi pour toi light night
imagine tu rencontres une fille nuit ce
serait quoi pour toi là reitman
accomplir tout ce que j'ai envie de
regrouper
les allées dîner ces développements
train de faire l'amour
adoré cette femme
ce qui fait que tout homme quand il est
avec une femme gentille dame beaucoup
partagé la compagnie
nous les hommes on imagine tout un plan
quand nous rencontrons nous ça mais
parfois les choses se passent pas comme
prévu parce que c'est pas la bonne nuit
ou que c'est pas le bon moment mais si
c'est la bonne nuit avec un peu de
musique de barry white ça marche
ce soir tu as concert au zénith dépêche
toi tu veux être en retard travail
allait bientôt tu vas être sur scène
ça va durer deux heures deux heures
qu'est ce que tu souhaites exprimé aux
gens pour cette fin d'année
mon amour ma reconnaissance pour l'année
qui vient de s'écouler l'espoir d'une
année nouvelle encore plus prospères
comme le message c la musique et l'amour
partout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hélas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors jean pierre c'est combien tienne
dakar petitdemange de manhattan mon
troisième le premier ça fait pas trop
mal passé et j'ai cassé juste avant
agadez alors j'étais 3e par contre mon
deuxième est bien ça s'est très mal
passé puisque
après 20 km de pistes et bien puis s'est
arrêté là mais d'accord
alors don d'un j'attaque le troisième
est là j'espère aller agadez et surtout
ce que j'espère c'est arrivé à dakar
parce que le paris dakar avant tout
c'est d'arriver à coeur et c'est là
toute aventure et c'est quoi ta plus
belle histoire du dakar en y en a plus
dans l'histoire du dakar s'est passé
avec mon équipe et de l'époque qui était
michel sardou la première année l'année
où
[Musique]
on a cassé on a dû casser vers 5 heures
de l'après midi en plein désert en plein
délire et il est très chaud on est
attendu un petit peu l'assistance a
essayé de réparer on s'est aperçu qu'on
pouvait pas réparer là on a demandé à
notre assistance de nous ramener à
agadez verts étaient 300 ou 400 km de
pistes et à ce moment là notre
assistance nous attirer et
onze heures du soir dans l'est on relève
déjà depuis deux heures mais avec deux
voitures dans le sable on roulait à 30 à
l'heure et dans 5 ou là la corde c'est
un cap qui nous tire est prêt à casser
et
michel voyant partir les feux rouges de
la voiture de devant nous avait
l'impression ils sont en train de
plaisanter c'est moi je dis non moi je
suis un certain qu'ils en ont marre nous
dire à 30 à l'heure c'est à casser on
les reverra plus et on s'est retrouvé
avec michel à une heure du matin en
panne puisque déjà en panne et planté en
plein désert l'exotique way est bien là
bas j'ai dit bon on va attendre
le lendemain matin j'irai service verra
nous chercher avec son hélicoptère
et michel on a une petite malade de
survie et qui permet de il ya des lampes
des fusées valise et michel à jouer avec
ça parce que bon on était peut-être un
peu anxieux ouais et puis la ville
allant tout le monde qui est clair de
très loin qui fait des flashs hélas ce
moment là il ya non ballet qui est passé
mais comme en fin de compte on n'était
pas vraiment sur la piste on était un
petit peu à un kilomètre à droite le cas
ben daley a perdu sept dents paul ouin
est venu nous chercher hélas bien
débuter d'enfer avec michel blanc de
michel ce sera énorme et man eh bien on
a fait on est arrivé le lendemain
d'après midi à agadez recouvert de ça
parce qu'on était à l'arrière du camion
il y avait des gens qui avaient des
jambes cassées dont il y avait des gens
qui étaient pour pâques ces voitures qui
étaient en voiture balai et là on était
recouvert de poussière et on était très
content d'eux enfin de découvrir régalé
c'est de pouvoir prendre une douche et
cette année tu le fais avec qui m alors
cette année grâce à paul ten on le fait
avec deux porsche et avec jacques
laffite et en même temps ami et beau
frère
je crois que
on est une très très bonne équipe on a
deux voitures de forge très bien
préparée par porsche on a une très bonne
assistance on a trois véhicules
rapprocher comme on dit plus de camions
et je crois sincèrement qu'on a vraiment
une équipe on est sûrement pas au niveau
de peugeot ouais parce que vos jours
très très gros bras jan paul ten a mis
de gros moyens aussi et je crois
sincèrement
tourné dans les outsiders et qu'on
devrait être très proche moi je suis sûr
que si on arrive à dakar eh bien on sera
dans les cendres au musée mais voila
voila c'est ton pronostic
avaya
[Musique]
il
beignets
[Applaudissements]
m
et
[Musique]
2 m
tu mets gameiro hallyday
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as aimé
[Musique]
[__]
mon pilotage
[Musique]
m
à
j'ai vu le sang
[Musique]
m
rap et rebelle cause quel chef des
sapeurs-pompiers je suis une sorte
le guide des sapeurs bits des sapeurs
les mises à pleurer par un créateur
en qui on vient de voir la belle à
sédhiou ballard que j'aime sommes
aujourd'hui à partir d'aujourd'hui le
pape de la sape parce que l'année passée
les trois quatre ans que la boad la stap
on est jeune homme le pape mais toi t'es
quoi si les pattes et au dessus des
dieux de la sia principal de l'assam
l'issue de sa rencontre pour un savant
la création donc toi tu es le savon
créateurs puis il est devenu aujourd'hui
pape de la sable et qui en a vu d'autres
et là vous avez des deux les deux
suivants salé nyanza à la nasa qui et
quoi qu'ils aient le croyant de la same
way
est ce pour cela qu'il a encore qui n'a
pas pu mettre les costumes en outre
l'egypte il commence à s'intéresser au
sort des personnes aînées grande qu'ils
ont bien sûr les société des ambianceurs
des personnes
la définition de la salle et le
troisième se déguiser troisième c'était
ma terre du nord si le phénomène reste à
bord il n'est pas mannequin avant la
taille mais il est danseur batteur
il aime le style là ça peut supporter
uniquement en même temps il faut que
nous explique l'esprit de la seule à
l'esprit la sape
l'esprit actuel à sa place dans l'espace
de la salle c'était d'abord on est ton
apaisé les esprits parce que ça leur
offre est toujours co créé toujours
latino universal et maintenant depuis
les années c4 25 on a essayé de créer de
nouveaux modèles pas nous mêmes par
rapport à aller ce qu'on voulait pas ce
que tu entends pas bien les boutiques
ils sont alors entourée de beaux trucs
mais qui convenait pas vraiment évaluer
les modifications pour se mettre à les
âges c'est sûr ça fait maintenant
c'était trop trop classe ça fait un peu
trop c'est sûr qu'en dise voilà
maintenant vous avez fini vers angers
saint laurent est votre gouvernement
n'ont pas dj augustin laurent vous êtes
ce soir c'est l'enquêteur d'intéressant
yahoo estime aussi que très important
weston reste hurle le dieu le dieu des
chaussures ouais et maintenant c'est la
mode la mode en combinaison si vous
voulez c'est à dire entre le serveur et
le créateur donc le sapeur on ne peut
venir une idée est le créateur réaliste
guider à travers le dessin et à travers
la coupe
c'est un post une bonne a créé depuis
les années quatre-vingt cinq ans dix ans
parce qu'on atteindra desclaux cameron
accueillis et c'est une complicité du
dépôt deux ans lassé de penser à ce
qu'on lit écoute on peut faire un
costume tu peux faire à la fois hiver
était presque autant et voilà vous avez
monté ça c'est un manteau une chemise
baisse vers blida une
petite chemise d'un costume d'un costume
que peut flâner avec moi pendant tout
quatre temps saluait été peinte en
automne hiver et été à l'aise là dedans
y'a pas de problème ont été faire une
garde une cadrée mais costil
sur les 5 la chaîne du dakar sans que ce
noir et blanc merci bernard
[Musique]
fait nouveau il y en a et m
roy qui les a nommés
[Musique]
konami
betty lotois
[Musique]
pour s y voyait mal au bar
c'est la base
marignane dans la mairie
[Musique]
ces canailles et son nez
clope au delà des combats
malgré six magasins
lina monnaie
pour les noces
[Musique]
voilà merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
et si canaille et décennies
[Musique]
là
les bitumes aguilar
huningue à bagnac
motogp lynam avérée
[Musique]
et
à
allo
[Musique]
quand la puissance
youpi
et là et minuit
mais là
notre pays n'a
montré
on oublie
[Musique]
que mehdi donnant
douleur
[Musique]
rémy d'une enquête
aviron
alors qu à tour chaque mardi oui je te
connaissais pas je craque complètement
bon sens franchement qu'est ce que tu
fais moi je suis mannequin à paris je
prends paris un ailleurs avec saint
laurent dior c'est à côté tu change pas
les modèles tous les pores exact 1 et tu
es doué à l'origine du sénégal et
comment ça s'est passé et quelqu'un
quitte à trouver la baute venu ici mais
je suis venu comme tous les africains
qui quitte un jour je ferai jamais envie
de faire quelque chose ailleurs et des
glaires il va trouver j'ai commencé avec
lui et après j'ai travaillé
j'ai merdé
philippe [__] blanc paul and mary
c'est les yeux bleus c'est bon parce
qu'en parler de toi tout à l'heure
actuelle aux chiffres il en dise est
condensé sur mission impossible avec
ouais mais ici donc là quand même été
disquaires débats à l'ouverture c'est
pas rien si après tout à fait délicieux
fetwa par le quai ce qui lasse negro
negro là et puis t'as fait quoi d'autre
j'avais fait un excellent temps mes
oreilles qui aurait flop proton je m'en
souviens pas et là j'en ai un qui
s'appelle justicier pour du parti or
l'écart à janvier et je fais vidéo avec
jean baptiste mondino une bonne marque
bonne marque qui va vite tu va nous
donner en exclusivité dans ma demi nue à
faudrait que la même
[Musique]
mais tu dis à londres ou à paris map
parce que moi je suis très souvent à
londres parce que j'ai signé un contrat
avec les américains aïe aïe aïe aïe on
verra pu alors
c'est quoi alors le clip avec jean ba tu
veux pas en parler un peu si j'ai un
truc un peu électrique cowboys à bord
électriques or ce n'est
très drôle
[Musique]
alpha blondy sweet fanta diallo ça c'est
un tube la vie dont
[Musique]
oui
non
oh
suite
le nouveau maire
[Musique]
diallo
ce
n'est pas
en vue
[Musique]
gym estimé
non dans
[Musique]
diallo
groupe
[Musique]
en tant que maman
suite
diallo au bouc
[Musique]
diallo
trop
[Musique]
capital
d'aia
toi
ça car les attraits
et toi
ça rien trouvé
bétaillère
[Musique]
normalement a dit
non a dit
[Musique]
manon a dit durant
trois noms à d'idiot
nous allons à quillan
noah non à dijon
[Musique]
même la gérante
m
[Musique]
la famille
alors ce rallye dean tous en bas vous
c'est radio nova bonsoir alors quoi ça
fait depuis le début de l'émission me
dit on très vite ce rallye rappellent à
ce que tu as fait les soirées aubin qui
s'appelle éléphants blancs des soirées
génial et puis maintenant qu'ils
occupent en entre autres choses de la
programmation musicale d'une émission
sur radio nova qui est autour de minuit
et qui s'appelle comment autour du mur
autour de mémoire tu te conduire des
politiques 1
c'est que des compactes
il faut moderniser des jazz aussi ouais
tu fais bien oui
c'est un programme - et le fond blanc
nous bah ouais sur la radio c'est
l'émission dont on parle en tous les cas
qu'est ce que tu fais bintou dans cette
émission un toit pendant cette émission
mais sur radio nova en général on des
membres de l'équipe qui anime aussi
cherchent des disques
vous allez québécois semblent pas bon je
suis le noctambule a comme tu souffres
de l'asthme cela va être difficile pour
toi tu as beaucoup de fumée et on a un
très vieux d'avoir là mais ça va arrêter
bien alors maintenant montrer new delhi
et puis avant d'avoir des groupes à ne
pas en vous abonnant comme ça un certain
nombre de disques wave ils s'en sont les
mots travers la wii on parle de déclin
de la chanson française alors la
constance justement d'avoir amené à
chanter disent
que cet ancien combattant qu'est l'état
d'anciens combattants fêtant buffet
propre toit en zinc de l'afrique un
deuxième disque corbillard très
économique c'est d'actualité
de tonton marion dumas vient du gabon
est encore descendu en ce moment sans le
bar d'accord et un disque qui vient de
sortir trans connexion ça ce sont tous
les jeunes deuxième génération
camerounaise d'origine camerounaise
d'origine antillaise pablo master series
cas où dit qui chante qui sont le reggae
plus tôt mais en france m maintenant on
s'assied francophone du côté de
l'afrique afrique centrale sera lui
l'art ce rallye est bien règlement qui
est appris que le juge des libertés
s'est adressé ses très orchestrée du
rock
le label a été créé cette année par le
devoir à pic avant d'atteindre une part
à piennes gens presque 10 et ont même
pas tous les grand sapin ameur oublier
des apports qui me demandait de passer
les listes de zaïko langa langa un
certain regard qui viennent de faire de
très bons chevaux à la mutualité qui
sombrait l'entreprise d'un coup
l'anglais
côté afrique de l'ouest
il se la voir dehors à 112 mory kanté
est le roi de la chorale produit par
barclays pense que
le regarde c'est appréciable soit
produit par des grandes maisons de
disques de son dernier disque accolade
beach ça va marcher avec une chaleur et
en afrique de l'ouest vers le sénégal
ouais le meilleur groupe qui vivent au
sénégal à kayes à l'intérieur c'est
super boulot super bien mené super
diamono de dakar est très rapidement il
ya aussi plein de
fric le bob dylan africain certains
disent même et puis on a préparé aussi
quelques autres disent que tu viennes
d'ailleurs par exemple le premier zoulou
car cette année ça a été l'explosion de
johnny clegg et savuka mais avant avec
six ans il était dans dans ce groupe
joue luca on a découvert comme ça sur
nova ces deux dernières années des
rythmes dansants qui vont d'ailleurs pas
seulement de l'afrique francophone donc
ce disque qui distribue en france il est
très bien georges darko ça c'est du
ghana c'est très dansant aussi enfin
toujours du zouk ans lorsque je vous
conseille de danser sur le high life
time fernando luiz as et le mozambique
avec les influences et plutôt
portugaises ces 45 tours très dense à
pour les sept autres séquelles t elle
vos envies ou angola tandis que vous en
dites voilà ça aura lieu lundi que le
jazz quand même un truc à un lieu
charmant
qui habite à l'union il a son propre
robe grosses écuries scénario t il ya et
le live enregistré chez parker avec
steve là ici avec tout ce qu'on a c'est
chez lui il a le portrait de duke
ellington bla et tout va bien parce que
de toute façon
tout le music directe ou indirecte
african provient des eaux bien des
ordinateurs a jusqu'à lors d'une séance
jusqu'à 15 b si tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
touré kunda carradine deal dakar est
parti
[Musique]
maintenant
morita
[Musique]
6 1
là
[Musique]
rien
paul armagnac et ils vont fauconnier
bonsoir vous êtes dans les dents les
équipages qui prenaient le départ tout à
l'heure pour le dakar un couple assez
particulier parce que d'abord toi tu
viens de la mer et toi tu viens du
désert c'est marrant c'est dans vous
soyez mélanger tous les c'est donc un
bon mariage qui espère donnera des bons
résultats parce que
la rencontre entre le désir et la mer
est quelque chose
qui sera sûrement très intéressant ils
vont fauconnier et un grand marin qui a
déjà fait ses preuves je pense qu'il
racontera tout à l'heure des trois très
belles choses et le cdh en ce qui
concerne la navigation
bien assurée de
le palau père antoine a noté un enfant
du désert tlhagale s je suis originaire
bagdad fils né à une centaine de
kilomètres dans la galère je vis
donc depuis toujours dans la région
cette partie là je pense que nous
n'aurons pas du tout de problème et
navigation que je reconnais parfaitement
et ils vont en ce moment pourrait
cependant quelques vacances et faire des
photos seins des maternelles d'arriver
là-bas il faut qu'il vient vérifier bien
ouverts et des regards des chartistes
mais alors comment un enfant d'agadès ou
de la région un pue est rentré dans dia
car comment ça s'est passé c'était une
histoire tout à fait
spécial parce que paris là car je vais
d'abord il passé depuis un certain
nombre d'années parce qu'ils passent aux
légions de plus 80 un parent est dans un
premier temps ces demandes et toujours
qui s'est dit c'est du passé
blizzard et qu'il pourrait traverser la
vie on comprend pas il ya un mouvement
de rue peel
et on s'en approche petit à petit on se
fait des amis
de gourcuff et un puck finalement et
c'est pas si mauvais qu'on a souvent
tendance à lire c'est comme ça que j'ai
rencontré ici comme certains jours j'ai
fait la rencontre des petits riches amis
au pied de l'arbre du ténéré en 80
croire et on est devenus très amis par
la suite on a pris quelques
reconnaissances ensemble les forces de
baliser les différents aucun doute
générer ici un b basée sur le fait que
je connaissais pas mal la région pour
lui faire des traces et trouver de
nouveaux parcours balisé ensemble et
toute cette amitié qui avait un trou
d'où un jour il va demander pourquoi tu
ne partirai pas sur les paris dakar et
c'est comme ça que s'ils ont
pratiquement une espèce de paris je me
suis retrouvé un jour voyant une voiture
de rallye
[Musique]
il accuse m
il a fait le texte la musique le décor
la mise en scène il s'appelle david
rachline ça s'appelle paris gipsy ses 46
rue quincampoix jusqu'au 6 janvier nous
on adore
[Musique]
c'est quand on rêve tout éveillé et
qu'on se pince mon mieux crier heil et
que ceux criés
on l a dit rêver c'est avec carey
majuscule ajouté comme un matricule au
pyjama de satin elle se promène la vie
rêvée c'est aussi dans les rues de paris
pire à n'importe qui et thouaré stature
et la vie
mais c'est surtout
et que nous importons
touché à suivre
on vit un rêve lille rêver c'est la
virée du samedi soir après que l'on ait
le t-bond soir à la semaine et au qatar
aux idées sont virés b c'est pire il n'y
avait que des amis ou les dans les rues
de paris à trois ou quatre dans cet
accident c'est plus le nombre la
bbc tellement
plus doux et plus charmant
encore plus envie kelly champagne
les santons et
ans et jusqu'à la mort
enterrer son temps
la campagne
la virée des c'est rêver sa vie comme on
veut rêver tout en ouvrant les yeux et
voir briller dans la nuit
l'étoile filante lundi le raid et celles
à suivre à travers le ciel et puis faire
la course avec elle afin de lui dire
cette charmante eu la vie rêvée c'est
bien sûr
et à toute allure
avec sur ses chaussures
petite elle dit
c'est toujours
au pays de l'amour
l'éternel
commentaire
irene
on sait sous peu juste
dung
des jeux
[Musique]
oh
en écoutant
harvey
aubert chose
viré
dans des draps de sel blanc m n'est pas
dans ses coûts il est
il serait il est
hauser
[Musique]
oc
avi
ou tu en prends les
c'est
admirez
et elle
[Musique]
eh ouais
[Applaudissements]
voire en années je souhaite une émission
plus fréquente beaucoup plus de
rock'n'roll et
une maquilleuse dingue pour moi tout
seul chez un négociant way et pour la
paix pour le moment qu'est ce que tu
sois 90 je souhaite du rock and roll je
souhaite une maquilleuse pour tout le
monde
et beaucoup de neige toute l'année
du nord mais les mecs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour cela qu'on souhaitait pour la bonne
année à vous
accueillir 10 par mois d'argent et au
monde qui était un vous que thierry
ardisson donne son argent il en a paul
proust
et sylvain qu'est-ce que tu te souhaite
pour la bonne année je fais 50 photos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors voyez à la chandelle
[Rires]
[Musique]
bonne année moche à thierry et moi
pour garder plus longtemps
bonne année tu te bonne année fibre
nommé thierry médinois bonne année bien
c'est lui qui nous a présenté ses lyrics
et j'espère que cette présentation savin
veilleuse pendant des heures on va se
marier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alwihda
m
j'arrête là par la caa
c
voilà
cette formule
tarby
l'écart
j'avais ça
garda
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
o o
chalon s'est pas
[Musique]
j'avais mal de temps mais dit-il
jamais
m
capitale
[Musique]
hier
tu auras pas
[Applaudissements]
le carnaval
tôt ou tard
jobs
car
[Musique]
1987 l'année gipsy à tous ceux qui n'ont
pas pu les voir là si bien la 5 et 20
min offre le final du concert en
d'alegria
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charvaux legacy est amarré
l'entrée les la comptable
maintenant la battant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
la mode est complet avec tom
et
pas banal
à temps
[Musique]
mais l'attenté
bordeaux
dépenser mais
hélas
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais il attend m
bahia
k
[Applaudissements]
bilatéraux
villa
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu